esta es una pregunta que podría
encontrarse en un examen de economía y
que trata de mercados de competencia
perfecta nos dicen una empresa típica
que busca maximizar su ganancia en una
industria de competencia perfecta con
costo constante tiene una ganancia
positiva la primera pregunta que nos
hacen es a es el precio del mercado
mayor a menor
o igual al precio de la empresa explica
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
por su cuenta vamos a resolverlos juntos
estamos hablando de un mercado de
competencia perfecta y en un mercado de
competencia perfecta todos los
participantes del mercado tienen que ser
precio aceptantes por lo que no tienen
poder de modificar el precio así que el
precio del mercado tiene que ser igual
al precio de la empresa
el precio del mercado es igual al precio
de la empresa
por qué
en un mercado
de competencia perfecta
las empresas
son precios aceptantes
muy bien ahora nos dicen dibuja gráficas
lado a lado etiquetadas correctamente
para el mercado y para la empresa típica
donde muestres lo siguiente y nos piden
varias cosas más
de nuevo pausa en el vídeo y traten de
pensar en cómo resolver cada uno de
estos sub incisos les será de mucha
utilidad intentarlo veamos nos piden
gráficas lado a lado y nos piden el
precio y la cantidad del mercado ya
hemos hecho esto en varios vídeos
esta es la gráfica del mercado el eje
vertical es el del precio y el eje
horizontal es la cantidad del mercado y
ahora dibujaremos la gráfica de la
empresa este es el eje del precio de la
empresa y este es el eje de la cantidad
de la empresa y para que quede claro
escribimos que esta es la gráfica del
mercado y esta es la gráfica de la
empresa veamos el precio y la cantidad
del mercado son peso m y q sub m la
curva de oferta del mercado
luce así con una pendiente ascendente ya
lo hemos visto varias veces y la curva
de demanda del mercado de luce así
aquí tenemos el precio de equilibrio del
mercado que etiquetamos p sub m y aquí
tenemos la cantidad de equilibrio que
etiqueta moscú sub m ya resolvimos este
primer inciso veamos que más nos piden
la cantidad de la empresa etiquetada q
sub y la curva de ingreso promedio de la
empresa etiquetada y p la curva de costo
total promedio de la empresa etiquetada
ctp y el área que representa el costo
total sombreada completamente para
responder esta primera parte
pensamos cuál es la cantidad racional
que produce esta empresa que busca
maximizar sus ganancias tenemos que
pensar en el ingreso promedio de la
empresa y el ingreso promedio que es lo
mismo que la curva de demanda de la
empresa se va a basar en este precio del
mercado recuerden que la empresa en este
mercado de competencia perfecta es
precio aceptante esta recta horizontal
es la curva de ingreso promedio de la
empresa
que es igual al ingreso marginal img que
a su vez es igual a la curva de demanda
y que también es igual al precio del
mercado y la cantidad racional que
produce está donde la curva de ingreso
marginal que también es la curva de
ingreso promedio intersec aa la curva de
costo marginal
cmg y esto de aquí es q sub
con lo que resolvimos esta parte y esta
parte la curva de costo total promedio
de la empresa etiquetada ctp bueno el
costo total promedio en esta cantidad
tiene que estar por debajo del ingreso
marginal y el ingreso promedio en esta
cantidad porque sabemos que la empresa
tiene una ganancia económica positiva
por lo que tenemos una situación que
luce más o menos así es la curva de
costo total promedio y la dibujé de esta
forma para asegurar que en este punto de
curso
el ingreso marginal y el ingreso
promedio estén por arriba del costo
total promedio que es lo que nos dice
que se tiene una ganancia económica
positiva en esta situación por lo que ya
resolvimos
esta parte el área que representa el
costo total sombreada completamente
bueno el área que representa al costo
total será el costo promedio por unidad
qué es esto multiplicado por el número
total de unidades producidas el número
total de unidades producidas es esta
longitud que es igual a q sub y por lo
que el costo total será toda esta área
sombreada si nos preguntaban por toda la
ganancia económica entonces hablaríamos
de esta área de acá arriba pero no es lo
que nos piden solo se refieren al costo
total que es esta área de aquí ya
terminamos con todos estos sub incisos
ahora veamos el inciso c si una empresa
en el mercado subiera sus precios qué
sucedería con su ingreso total explica
pausa en el vídeo y vean si pueden
resolverlo recuerden que estamos en un
mercado de competencia perfecta en una
industria en competencia perfecta en
donde los productos de todos son
homogéneos y si de pronto a alguien se
le ocurre esta idea de aumentar sus
precios pues nadie
comprará sus productos ya que las
personas pueden obtener productos
idénticos con otras personas por un
precio menor así que su ingreso total
sería cero porque el producto
es homogéneo
los consumidores
pueden comprar
con otros
a menor precio otra forma de pensar en
esto es que las empresas tienen que ser
precio aceptantes en un mercado de
competencia perfecta